hey Siri Wow wowie hey while we you guys
are new here I say while we all the time
and I am gonna present blame my friend
Edie for saying it once and then me
laughing really hard about it and now we
say well we all the time now that I've
calmed down from the Siri while we I
just wanted to make a follow-up video to
sum the home pod videos that I made
because I made a lot of them I made a
bunch I made an unboxing I did a review
basically showing the features of the
home pod but this was before I really
spent much time with it having spent at
least a week with the home pod I will
say it sounds absolutely incredible that
is something that no one can deny I
listen to a lot of music all day long
when I'm working editing doing whatever
I always have music playing securely
judging this thing as a speaker and a
music playing device it is beyond
fantastic one of the things that I think
people are comparing this a lot to is so
knows because Sonos has really great
sound qualities I have so no speakers
all throughout my house in every room I
have one speaker whether it's a very
small one or in the kitchen I have a
very large one that produces a lot more
sound it's one of their newer ones I
don't have any of the Alexa powered
Soto's though all the ones that I have
are from the past few years the mass
appeal for me of the Sonos is playing
them and never seen the room and right
now this little guy is not capable of
that and that is a huge huge letdown I
bought a few of them this is the most
recent purchase I got to this space gray
one so that would match my Space Gray
iMac obviously in my IMAX setup video I
hadn't got this one yet so I was still
using the white one but this definitely
fits with the desk aesthetic much more
but all those things aside what has it
been like spending a week with the home
pod since then I've had a home 5 party
and I've spent plenty of time with a
home pod I've also converted my entire
house over to everything home kit
whereas before I would specifically use
the hue app but now everything is voice
enabled through Siri I turn my lights on
off I've enabled routines when I come
home or I leave so certain lights will
turn on I have motion activity so now
everything is integrated with home kit
where this falls flat it's very very sad
for me because I really do love this
thing a lot especially being an Apple
fan this just fits into my entire Apple
ecosystem
and of course you guys know I'm a huge
Apple fan so yes I'm slightly biased but
what I'm not biased about is my love of
Sonos I have a loved Sonos for so long
they sound great but the sound quality
in comparison of this to some of their
smaller speakers this definitely is much
better quality well that being said
these sono speakers are less expensive
you can also get two of the Alexa
powered so no speakers for the same
price as this guy but this looks so
incredible and yes it is Siri in abled
but no it is not as smart as Alexa or
Google and that is the real unfortunate
reality but the thing is all of those
things are software updates so easily
this can have the potential to be the
next Alexa or the next Google home but
right now in its current state those two
are still far superior they've also been
around a lot longer but Siri has also
been around for quite a while I still
feel like Siri has not unlocked her full
potential but again it's a software
update so now the ball is in Apple's
Court
let's get Siri to the level of Alexa and
Google and then we're talking this did
not ship with his full capabilities
without airplay - you're not able to
play in different rooms you're not able
to sync them all up together I wanted to
have one in every room I really wanted
this to be a Sony's replacement but
right now it can't be because I cannot
play music all throughout my house at
the same time that's not going to be
available until airplay - so that should
be later sometime this year and you also
aren't able to do stereo speakers so if
you want to do surround sound and have
two of these set up in front of your TV
and watch a movie on Apple TV because
that's the only way that you can use
them if only there was a way to sync
this to your television with an optical
cable like there is for the Sonos of the
sound bar that would be really really
awesome so the reality is the home pot
is not as smart as Alexa or Google but
the good news is she definitely has the
potential to be these things are easily
updated with software so now it's
basically just apples choice thanks
Alexa another thing that I feel like my
home pod and my Apple music it's well
it's not a bad thing but I feel like I
bought a lot of music around 2002 my
Apple music tends to supply me with a
lot of music from like the early 2000s
hey Siri play me some music here's a
personal
oh station built just for you let's kick
things off with some Third Eye Blind
every time look I mean I still AM like a
huge Third Eye Blind fan hey Siri stop
playing but it's so crazy because it's
still definitely favours music that I've
purchased over music that I've recently
streamed using Apple music so I've been
doing a lot of work kind of retraining
Apple music to like my interests now so
I didn't start really using Apple music
until I got a car the supported apple
carplay so before that I've just been
using Spotify because I had so many
great Spotify playlists that I didn't
want to completely convert over so now I
think that I'm using Apple music more
than Spotify mostly because I do drive a
lot so I tend to be talking to Siri a
lot in my car so because of that Apple
music has slowly taken over Spotify but
I'm still I absolutely love Spotify and
another thing that a lot of people are
complaining about is you're not able to
use third-party music apps with this so
you can but it has to be playing on your
phone so essentially if you want to
listen to Spotify you have to airplay it
to your home pod from there you can
still get some sort of smart commands
you can ask for specific questions if it
is in the database live what's this song
when was this long release play another
song on this album so those types of
things still sort of will work depending
upon what app you're using but my
overall thoughts of having spent plenty
of time with this over the past I guess
at this point maybe a week and a half
almost two weeks I'm definitely looking
forward to the airplay to update so I'll
be able to play stereo music I'll be
able to play music in all of my rooms
but right now I just have one in my
office one in my kitchen and one in my
living room I was thinking about getting
them for surround sound for my TV but I
probably won't because I already have
the Soto sound bar integrated into my
televisions so I would love to have them
there but since I can't really use them
we're just watching normal TV you can
only use it while you're watching Apple
TV I feel like they would get more use
other places in the house so I think a
lot of people may be on the fence if
they want to buy a home pod or not and I
think if you're looking to get one now I
would say do it if you're looking to get
more than one I would say potentially
wait until airplay 2 is out unless you
just want to get them anyway and just
wait patiently for it to actually be
unlocked to its full potential but until
then I will be the one waiting patiently
but know this will not be replacing my
Alexa anytime soon I feel like there's
so much that I have integrated into
Alexa that she is just sort of another
addition to my smartphone essentially so
I hope you're having fun with me are you
having fun with me so far
hmm that's something I don't know Oh No
come on girl calling me hanging in front
all my friends play me some music okay
let's press play
starting with paper shoes by Incubus
what was the song released paper shoes
by Incubus came out on November 22nd
2006 it's not playing I also haven't
noticed the white ring happening because
I don't really have a lot of wood
services in my house I don't know if any
of you guys have experienced that let me
know in the comments below if you have
molted my services are either mirrored
reflective or this just like a white
lacquer so I have not run into that at
all yet that's also kind of an
unfortunate thing and I feel like
Apple's response was a very Apple
response like respond they're like well
just don't put it on a wood surface so I
guess don't put it on a wood surface all
things considered I really like the home
pod and I'm not just saying that because
I'm a huge Apple fan girl I love small
compact speakers this looks good any
room it matches my setup perfectly as
far as Siri being smarter yeah it's
definitely a possibility there's a lot
of things that she is lacking in
comparison to alexa and google home but
again is a software update so fingers
crossed that all of these things happen
very very quickly well thank you guys
for watching I would love to hear you
guys thoughts I know you have a lot of
thoughts because I've been hearing them
quite often on Twitter I will see you
guys in my next video let me know if you
have any suggestions for things you
would like to see here and if you're not
subscribed already subscribe and if you
feel like it if not it does really
matter cuz I don't feel like YouTube
subscriptions really should make a
difference anymore see you later
my little girl hey Siri do you like to
be picked up this is about you not me it
is actually unreflecting because I do
not like to be picked up okay hey Siri I
oh okay
no go by for me no go back for you
[Music]